[موسيقى]
عاد ماثيو فان دايك للتو من سوريا حيث كان
يعمل على اعداد فيلم عن الثائرين ضد نظام
بشار
الاسد اجل انني مطلوب للنظام السوري
وهنالك تهديدات امنيه حتى من جانبنا
فالموقف غايه بال الخطوره لكنني ساعود الى
سوريا مجددا حارب فان دايك قبل هذه المره
مع الثوار الليبيين وهنا يرين بطاقته
العسكريه اذ خدم ضمن جنود المشاتل وكان
مسؤولا عن اطلاق الاسلحه الثقيله اؤمن
بالاراده الذاتيه وارى بانه من حق الناس
ان يطالبوا بتغيير قادتهم ويوجد الكثير من
الامريكيين الذين انضموا لصفوف الجيش
السوري الحر لمساعده الثوار في التخلص من
نظام الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد ويعد ايريك
هارون واحدا منهم وقد اتهمه النظام السوري
بالاشتراك مع مجموعه جبهه النصره التي
يعتبرها النظام ارهابيه ورغم ان الولايات
المتحده تريد استبعاد نظام الاسد الا انها
لا ترغ في الوقت ذاته ان تتحول سوريا الى
بؤره
للمجاهدين الموضوع يؤرق الولايات المتحده
خاصه عندما تجتمع الشبكات الارهابيه في اي
جزء من العالم وعندما يتدرب الامريكيون
على هذه الممارسات هل تعلم بوجود مقاتلين
اخرين من امريكا في سوريا لست على معرفه
شخصيه باي منهم لكن تلقيت ما بين 20 الى
30 رساله الكترونيه من قبل امريكيين يودون
القتال في سوريا ومعظمهم جنود المتقاعدين
من قوات مشه البح
ويريدون ان اعمل على تسهيل نقلهم الى
سوريا لكنني لا ارغب بذلك ويقول فان دايك
ان خلفيته العقائديه مختلفه عن هارون
هنالك فرق واضح بيننا اذ لم اتعامل مع
منظمه
ارهابيه وينظر فان دايك بمنزله الواقع في
مدينه بالتيمور الامريكيه الى القفل الذي
احكم على زنزانته خلال فتره سجنه في ليبيا
لمده سته اشهر ويقول انه سيعاود سفره الى
سوريا قبل نهايه الحرب m